ribas et d'une ex oui oui bien sûr à la
barre donc on a raison veillez à rester
cet homme se rappeler même pas sur moi
catherine sept ans ça me semble beaucoup
maeva faire qu'à la 10e place et si
possible ça jugé possible je lui fais
confiance et ce macho man ça a été une
belle histoire mais pas bon non c'est
pas beau j'en ai fait un bon paquet sur
les tgv du helmand et puis j'ai dit
c'est confiance que ça gêne à la forêt
voix mais oui il était mort c'est à dire
40 ans ma chérie tu es tu aimes bas
nettoie contraire ses 40 ans il ya 40
ans arrêté mais un petit peu de respect
pour kathrin welte l'adorent je serais
pas resté 7 ans et qu'elles ne seront
pas là elle a gâché sa temps de sa vie
bonjour jean mi je crois c'est connu il
ya longtemps souviens quand je vais sur
et les mots doux à l'oreille
à l'époque je comprenais tout maintenant
que je t'écoute dans l'émission du bas
voulu payer je ne comprends absolument
rien
ma question qu'est ce que tu fais ta
longue je n'enrage
[Applaudissements]
la question avec ta langue et on
embrasse catherine évidemment y avait
toujours des nouvelles d'elle ou par
mois non mais attendez nouvelle alors la
catastrophe dans la question c'est
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait que ma langue
oui le ch la question oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est ça que ça là c'est trop la
longue c'est toujours la broutille sort
gagnant mais il ya quoi pourquoi vous
ayez regarde les îles appelées de d2 et
son exceptionnelle alors été susurré à
l'oreille c'est ça qui est magnifique
est-ce que tesco notion de claque merde
ou bien la question que je sais bien que
mal en effet que ma langue je crois
qu'elle encore là heureusement il n'en
sera rien à boire au genou s'alarmer
d'abord il doit enfouir
c'est quoi la langue la langue bretonne
par la fois les coucher
[Rires]
cet indélicat
il avait le ballon mais non alors alors
oui voilà la question
j'embrasse mais la question que cet élan
je vais toujours c'est bine question
bon allez c'est bon voilà c'est pas cool
qui va priver ces gens là on dirait que
ça c'était les quarante ans j'avais 17
ans bientôt tu veux quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour masse très fort et jouera ses
soeurs le roi fort qu'apple et ses
parois qui j'étais allée magnifique
attachement vous êtes resté sept ans
lesquels elle soigne un petit podium le
mal choisi